METE ATAMEL:
Speech-To-Text API can
be used to convert audio
to text in 120 languages.
Let's see how to use
Speech API with C#.
First, make sure the API
is enabled in your project
and a service account
exists to make API calls.
Both are explained in the
codelab in the video notes.
In Cloud Shell, let's
create a simple dotnet
console app and add Speech API
NuGet Package to the project.
Open the Code Editor and
navigate to program.cs.
We will transcribe an audio file
saved on Google Cloud Storage.
First, reference to
the Speech API library.
Create a speech client.
Specify Speech
API configuration.
Point to the audio on
Google Cloud Storage.
Call Recognize method.
And finally, print the results.
Let's run the app.
There you go.
You just used the Speech-To-Text
API to convert audio to text.